so uh paris it's uh absolutely great to
get a chance to chat with you today and
i want to start off by saying uh thanks
for thanks for joining us uh from madrid
uh so for those on the on the webinar um
that have seen previous webinars
associated
with um with with this with this program
series of uh webinars uh for for the i2m
program that that that focus on a range
of of topics
and and and so the you know the topics
have included things like what what are
the top 10 things you should look for in
a venture capital store what are some of
the specific tips to getting funding
right and in this case we're going to be
talking about something that's really
important for
entrepreneurs to understand and that is
the topic of
specifically personal results and so uh
you know as anita had mentioned i am a a
professor uh in the school of
engineering at stanford and
serve as academic director for a lot of
our entrepreneurship and venture capital
training programs um but uh paris why
don't you introduce yourself to us in a
little more detail
specifically talking about um i.e if
folks aren't familiar with the ie
business school venture lab uh what
you're doing
and then after that we can
talk a little bit about your journey and
and
history of personal resilience
okay thanks mike it's a pleasure to be
here
um yeah i.e business school is a top 20
business school in the world and uh
we're based in madrid
we probably have some of the highest
diversity rates of any school in the
world about 95 percent of our students
are not are not spanish and classes are
in english
the entrepreneurship center which i run
with the venture lab
is number one in europe for business
schools and we're ranked about four or
five in the world
so we take entrepreneurship very
seriously the venture lab
i've been running the venture lab for
the last 12 years
over 1500 startups have come through the
venture lab in the last 12 years we have
about
close to a couple hundred
every year
and so
essentially what we find is that about
30 percent of our alumni from 25 to 30
percent actually become entrepreneurs
so yeah we you know uh we essentially we
do drink the kool-aid here um we push
people uh beyond the boundaries to uh
think like entrepreneurs
and a lot of them you know they get the
bug in them and by the time they
graduate they want to become
entrepreneurs or two or three years down
the line
and so
it's pretty serious stuff and you know
the the venture lab works across the
school undergraduates
in the technology school the masters in
management the mbas
so yeah it's uh it's a pretty uh
busy lab and i can say it's it's been a
hell of a roller coaster ride over the
last few years and especially during the
pandemic we found that more and more
people wanted to become entrepreneurs
yeah in indeed we're certainly seeing
the same things here and and and once
again i want to thank you for joining us
uh from a little bit later in the day
for you you know it's really this access
to world-class global experts that i
think makes uh the i2m program
specifically uh really special uh and
and your involvement in it as one of the
instructors and also one of the
participants in our in our webinar
series really really special
so i want to uh first um uh take a a and
take a minute and focus on your personal
journey because
the work that you've done to try to help
entrepreneurs understand this idea of
resilience and mindset is not one that
is purely academic in nature even though
you are a faculty member at a
world-class business school it's one of
a personal journey from you as well and
and so
i think it'd be helpful to take a few
minutes to talk about that that personal
journey that you've had to get to this
point and then we can jump off into some
of the findings uh that that your
research and our collaborative work to
date have resulted in
okay uh yeah you're right i i'm not your
typical academic um actually
my background is i grew up in la
and uh i decided to go to school in
boston i went to bu boston university i
did my bachelor's in mathematics there
and then i got my master's work in
computer science there
and so as you can see you know when i
graduated i was pretty much a nerd
uh i hated uncertainty in uh in my work
and i also hated it in my personal life
you know um i always tell the story of
my first girlfriend bonnie uh she when i
was 17 and uh she actually left me
because she said i was too boring and
too predictable
she said you know i always used to call
her at eight o'clock and i was like well
one time you want me to call you and she
says well can't you call me at like 8
15.
that might actually create some
excitement in our lives
and
yeah so i was pretty nerdy and it was
then that i realized that
you know when you're nerdy and you don't
like uncertainty in your personal your
professional life it's got you know
ramifications um and and so
what i saw very clearly you know when i
was doing i got my first job
and when i graduated in programming i
saw very clearly that i needed to find a
way to understand business better you
know i had to unnerve somehow
and i got really lucky a colleague of
mine from harvard
that was just across the river there he
uh he called me up and he said paris you
know i'd like to come to new york city
uh and work with me you know i'd like
you to run the sales desk in my real
estate investment firm
and uh you know i said sales i mean i'm
a nerd i can't do sales
and so he took me through this
incredible
training program which i'm not going to
bore you with tonight
but you can read about it in my thesis
and or some other also some other
tedxes that i've done but essentially he
put me through a six-month training
program that unnerted me i was forced
out of my comfort zone repeatedly um and
that i realized then that you know i was
like a it was like a muscle the more you
stretch this muscle of approaching
pushing yourself out of your comfort
zone and trying to understand other
forms of business
essentially what i was doing is
well before since i was so obsessed with
certainty
i saw fear i had fear with uncertainty
now for the first time after this
training program
i saw opportunity and uncertainty
and and that's truly what uh
differentiates a uh
an entrepreneur for most people well and
this is and this is i guess a little of
a prelude into what we're going to be
talking about and these foundations of
entrepreneurship uh is is this this
mindset of is it opportunity or is it
fear of uncertainty and how you view
this and we'll get to those in a little
bit so you're in new york you've done
this training program um uh i guess i
would say nothing wrong with being a
nerd um uh it's a wonderful way to it's
a wonderful way to get great jobs and
have a wonderful life but um but yeah
it's a different
so you do this training
then what happened
well i joined his um his investment firm
his real estate investment firm and i
was all you know i was only there for
six months when i got a call from wall
street and some guy union bank of
switzerland says to me listen uh we've
heard you're a pretty good salesman
and uh i said wow all the way to wall
street and so you know they i went to
see them they made me an offer i
couldn't refuse i went back to my boss i
said what do i do and he said listen uh
you've done your bid here you know your
future's in banking and that started my
career in investment banking i spent the
80s in new york city
and you probably read a lot of those
books liars poker and the rest uh those
were the most amazing years uh in new
york city i i was not a nice person
during those years i got to admit that
there was also a it was also a movie
with michael douglas and some other
things about that time and so uh yeah a
very interesting time in wall street
i i was not a good guy during those
years and uh so after 10 years in new
york doing investment banking i ended up
in london
at abn amro bank also doing investment
banking and then i became 42 in 2002 and
i decided i'd had enough
you know i became what i call a friday
person and you know i i tell this a lot
to my students you know i think there
are two types of people in the world
friday people and monday people
and you know whenever i've i've always
loved mondays because i love what i do
and you know the reality is that 40 of
our life is work so if you don't love
what you do i mean that's a sad reality
but the reality is that most people are
friday people
i mean you look at them and on thursdays
they're smiling because they're looking
forward to the weekend
and so i became a friday person in 2002
and i decided i got to get out of this
rocket
and i was very lucky to get the call
from sony in japan uh they said to me
that manchester united had canceled
their friendly match
and they were looking for an
entrepreneur to you know bring european
football teams to japan now i knew
nothing about soccer football and as an
american i'd even like soccer
but that night i couldn't sleep i said
to myself this is it this is my
opportunity
and i went to my wife and i said honey
i'm leaving the bank
and she said oh really where you going
goldman sachs morgan stanley maybe and i
said no
i'm going to become a sports marketing
professional
you should have seen her face
uh well that started my uh
my eight year sprint as an entrepreneur
i had five startups one in sports
did pretty well one in advertising
agency lost a lot of money a renewable
energy one that did well a crm company
software that did well and then i also
did the first person shooter game on
xbox connect video game that was a
disaster i lost a fortune amount
and so after eight years of being an
entrepreneur
i became a friday person again
i got fed up i said you know
you know i think it's i think it's
really important that folks on the call
also hear from from you know successful
academic successful entrepreneurs that
not everything is a series of successes
and in many many regards
entrepreneurship is a resilience
exercise in understanding how to learn
from failure and see failure as a growth
opportunity just as much as it is
the ability to move on to the next thing
so i appreciate you
honestly sharing the fact that you know
what that failed and it was a blaming
disaster
and so that's
really important thanks for sharing and
you've learned keep going so you're your
startups
and so yeah um i decided i was going to
become a professor
and you should have seen my wife's face
when i told her honey i become a friday
person again i want to i want to teach
and she looked at me and said
you know paris most people when they
change careers they make more money and
and you have gone i mean from being an
investment banker where we were rich to
being an entrepreneur where we didn't
know when the next paycheck was coming
to being a professor where we know that
they that paycheck is going to be very
small where we where we know there's no
paycheck coming
exactly and so uh for the last 12 years
i've been here at ie
um running the venture lab and uh
working
alongside the entrepreneurship center uh
but the big thing that you know really
pertains to this talk is my thesis
um i decided you know and i have to get
a phd because you know if you want to be
a teacher you got to be a phd otherwise
they're going to look at me and say
you're just some excellent message
banker and so my thesis director at the
time
i got my phd uh in spain um in barcelona
at a saturday
my phd director was from brown uh
university and he said to me listen
you need to find a topic that you can
relate to
and essentially when i told him the
story of my life he said listen you've
got to talk about the relationship that
we have with uncertainty
and essentially
i studied nerds
i studied those people that struggle
with ambiguity that are obsessed with
certainty
um and i and i i got to the point where
i was able to understand the difference
between one's relationship with
uncertainty in their personal life and
their professional life
you know and and so
i look at myself i haven't changed a lot
in my personal life i'm pretty much i'm
not a nerd but i'm more nerdy than not
but in my professional life you know
ever since i did that training program
back then
i just embraced uncertainty and that's
why i think this
this talk of resilience in uh
in uh in entrepreneurship is really
critical
and and you know
i think this this talk of resilience and
entrepreneurship uh particularly as it
stretches into our personal life
is is even more
important right now during the pandemic
when there is
indeed a lot of uncertainty related to
our professional lives and for those
that are entrepreneurs that level of
uncertainty is always there but you
layer that on with increased uncertainty
in our personal lives
and i i would imagine and i know this to
be the case for many entrepreneurs it's
overwhelming
because where you seem to have control
and and less uncertainty in your life
and i know
in our previous discussions you've
talked
about this balance between being okay
with uncertainty in one aspect of your
maybe your professional life but needing
a less uncertainty in your in your
personal life to buy that balance you
know during the pandemic
that that control over the level of
uncertainty in our personal lives has
indeed been been taken from us
and that's why this topic today of
developing resilient mindsets for
entrepreneurs i think is so important
totally mike and back to the pandemic
what we have
seen and in the research that we've done
um
[Music]
we've seen that
very much during the pandemic we've been
forced
to get more comfortable with uncertainty
we've been forced to
feel less fear about it i mean it was
like a train wreck you know hitting us
at the beginning of the pandemic but at
the same time
we're looking for less uncertainty in
our personal lives
i mean i had a i had a student of mine
an undergraduate and i'll never forget
this guy he was german and before the
pandemic i mean the guy was like
partying like crazy and you know he was
one of his projects that he wanted to
build was a dating app
uh because he thought that dating apps
had not advanced enough and so the
pandemic hits
and you know after lockdown we come back
we start having uh online classes
and i see the guy completely pivot
his uh his dating site and i go like so
what's going on here he says
i'm going to build a site that actually
is going to help couples create serious
long-lasting relationships
the guy is 18.
and i'm and i'm asking him so what are
you looking for in a relationship and he
says commitment now like what does
commitment mean for an 18 year old
and so i mean that's an extreme example
but
so many people they either bought a pet
i mean why did pets go like crazy i mean
pets became family members during the
pandemic
you know everybody was searching for
more meaning in their lives
during the pandemic and they were trying
to reflect on what was important to them
i mean we've come out of this much
richer as humans we've come out of this
you know having a better uh you know uh
sense of what's important and what isn't
uh with respect to our personal lives
and that's moved us you know far to the
left in terms of wanting more certainty
in our lives but professionally it's
been like a train wreck as i said and so
and what we're seeing is more and more
people are embracing uncertainty now and
they're realizing that they have to and
they have to see opportunity in it and
that but that's going to take resilience
because this is all about fear
absolutely absolutely well so one of the
things that we absolutely want to do
with every single one of our our
webinars in this series related to i2m
is leave folks with something of really
high value and and often we find that to
be things like checklists
things like small little guidelines um
something simple they can walk away from
and uh and
and trying to to improve who they are as
an entrepreneur uh because you know
within our programs we're really focused
on frameworks we're really focused on
giving people tools for how they should
think
we can't answer
every question an entrepreneur would
have everybody
different
and so
therefore sort of these these small
tools and frameworks to help folks think
about what they're doing is is what we
really like to focus on because we find
that to be a fundamentally uh sound way
to teach entrepreneurship and so you
know we've talked about five
underpinnings of entrepreneurial
resilience and so i'm gonna uh sort of
walk us through these one through five
and uh i'd love to hear your thoughts um
on
why you think each one of these is so
important from the work you've done um
your personal history the research
you've done at ie and your experience at
ventura
and so the first one and it's one we've
alluded to already in some regards is
the first underpinning see
opportunity
in uncertainty the entrepreneur has to
see uncertainty
as a source of opportunity
not a source of fear
can you talk a little more what you mean
by that and and some examples where
you've seen folks including yourself do
that effectively
okay
and this is a very important point
um
i like to put it in the context of your
comfort zone
you know we've heard forever people say
get out of your comfort zone
but everybody struggles with that
and why do they struggle with it because
inherently
they don't want to change as a person
many times
and so if you were able to disconnect
the personal from the professional
it would be a completely different story
if now i ask you get out of your
professional comfort zone
you're like sure
what do i have to do you want me to
speak in public you want me to go down
the hall and you know talk to a stranger
and you know
uh find out about you know hang out with
the marketing people if i'm a bit of a
nerd so you can deal with that
but if i ask you get out of your
personal comfort zone
and you're a nerd and you're on the
dance floor and i'm telling you to go up
to some girl and like ask her for a
dance
that's a completely different story
and so since this is all about fear we
can manage our professional fears
it's very difficult to manage your
personal fears
and so this bifurcation this bifurcation
of personal and professional and saying
look you can
you can stay who you are and true to
yourself
authentic while while allowing yourself
to grow and by separating these giving
people the freedom to embrace
uncertainty one of the questions that
came in from the audience is you know
what tactic and help us embrace
uncertainty i think you just provided
one
buy for kate totally you think about it
anchor you need to anchor who you are
okay now you were saying earlier what we
found the you know the
balance here we've studied over 20 000
people over the last 10 years and we
have found that 80 of the people
who embrace uncertainty
in their professional life entrepreneurs
innovators
they're nerds in their personal life
they don't like uncertainty the late
steve jobs
he denied uncertainty in his personal
life he embraced it professionally
guys like mark zuprker zuckerberg
richard branson all these guys they're
more nerdy in their personal lives and
they're embracing it professionally so
the reality is that we look for our
balance in our lives and so that makes
total sense
but the the sad thing today and this is
one of the key messages for young people
is that if you're nerdy if you're like
introverted you're shy
society and you know your parents
everybody's telling you
you should maybe be an engineer
or be a mathematician or an auditor
but the reality is that if you are nerdy
in your personal life you have a better
chance of going crazy in your
professional life in being a leader or
an entrepreneur or a unicorn founder you
name it
yeah indeed indeed all right so the
first one see opportunity in uncertainty
and an important part of that as best
you can bifurcating
so that you can you can you can view
that uncertainty as an opportunity
all right so the second one that that
you've that you've uh identified and i
think is an interesting one to talk
about
harness the emotions of
others
and and can you talk a little bit about
what you mean by harnessing the emotions
of others because sincerely about you
know taking advantage of people um but
but rather how do you in fact see
emotion and the connection of emotion
um to uncertainty as as a as a as an
opportunity
well let me tell you um what we found
also is that the more comfortable you
are with uncertainty
the more emotional intelligence you have
because there's nothing more uncertain
than people's emotions
and so we're living in a world today
where a very key part of resilience is
your emotional intelligence
and more and more companies are
realizing that this is critical
and this is from every you know every
angle that you look at let me give you
one angle for example
much of innovation today is the user
experience when you're talking to
millennials about 50 of them prefer the
user experience to the actual product
and why is that
because we're living in a world today
where young people
and everybody but in particular young
people
everybody is looking for meaning in
their lives
and they and you know if you want to
give people meaning in their lives you
have to give them something that gives
them meaning people are more concerned
about how you make them feel than what
you're doing or how you're doing it you
know it's like the simon sinek stuff
it's the why
because the why is what gives people
meaning i mean you take your average
secretary in japan she makes forty
thousand dollars a year but she's got a
louis vuitton bag and a rolex watch that
together are worth more than ten
thousand dollars
can she afford that
no
but she needs it it's not just status it
gives them meaning
and that's why luxury is such a key
factor today in so many people's lives
uh but you know from it from all these
big companies whether it's amazon um
whether it's alexa all these things that
we're doing out there you know it's all
about giving people meaning
and if you can create
user experiences that give people
meaning
you're going to get customers and you'll
be able to build solid relationships
with them i mean look at here you know
here's my iphone
people ask me you know do you have a
relationship with your iphone
sure i do it's like my dumb brother it
doesn't have to be the best phone in the
world or the fastest phone
but you know what i have a relationship
with my iphone
so harnessing people's emotions
is about being able to give them meaning
and understanding what gives people
meaning and that's why you know we need
people we need young people
to really develop their emotional
intelligence and you can do that in a
professional setting it's a lot harder
in a in a personal setting but you can
learn emotional intelligence at work
absolutely this this is something that
we know we can do training on and
there's a lot of opportunities in those
in those spaces you know i think it's an
also a very important point um when
you're talking about user experience you
know from for many entrepreneurs you're
so product focused what are the features
of the product what's my mvp you know
kind of going along through your your
checklist uh and and it's and it's often
easy to forget about that user
experience
and that you know
the the scale of product is more about
value creation
for your customer than it is about a
checklist of awesome features that you
can provide to them and even for b2b
customers you're still dealing with an
individual in procurement someone has to
sign on and say yes this is the product
i want this is the relationship i want
and so whether you're a b to c or a b to
b business i think this
of the emotions of others is a
very powerful thing that we have to
remember and absolutely increase our our
resilience as an entrepreneur and the
resilience of our business
all right so that the next thing that
you highlight in this list of five so
first was see opportunity uncertainty
and i'll continue to repeat these so we
kind of keep go through these five the
second was harness the emotions of
others
the third
making sure you know whether you're a
missionary
mercenary in your mindset and which one
you are and which one provides more with
a more resilient approach so missionary
versus mercenary what do you mean
okay
and i think this goes back to the why
you know um
simon signings why in the sense that
you know people are not interested in
what you do or how you do it but why you
do what you do
and
you know like i said a lot of people in
the world are friday people they don't
like what they do
and so they're going from paycheck to
paycheck
now when you love what you do
it doesn't feel like work
and that's why you know entrepreneurs
have this
this mindset of resilience
where the strength for that resilience
is beyond you know something external
it's intrinsic you know you have this
this mission
that you you're committed to doing
something
and so i always ask people are you a
mercenary or a missionary
because if you're a mercenary you're
only doing it for the
money and what are you gonna do with the
money runs up
you know we're living in a society today
and this applies not just for
entrepreneurship i think it also applies
to a lot of relationships between people
you know we're living in a society today
where everybody wants instant
gratification
and the day they don't get it
the day that they don't get this it's
like you know what i've had enough of
this relationship or i've had enough of
this job and they change
and so you need to decide for yourself
what is it that gives meaning in your
life
in order to do the things that you want
to do
and then you need to decide for yourself
how you're going to approach this
because just like in entrepreneurship
you can't tell an investor that you're
only doing it for the money
it's the same with everything if you're
looking for a job and you want to
interview at a job at a big company like
procter gamble you're not going to show
up there and say you know and they ask
you you know why do you want to work
here
oh
you know it's the money
yeah
yeah no it's uh it's it's
and it's and it's not that being an
entrepreneur
can't be a very very
profitable enterprise right
but we fi because obviously there are
many entrepreneurs here in silicon
valley that have done very well
but but but you're right that this
mindset of one saying you know this is
my mission and yes uh one of the
outcomes of it is that i may be wildly
successful but but you're right there
will be
very big highs and very deep lows on any
entrepreneurial journey and so when we
talk about resilience of mindset
by changing from this idea that rather
than a paycheck a tgif
i'm a tgim
uh
and thank goodness it's monday because
i'm back to doing what i love
to do and and and and this and this i
think this
difference between doing it for the
money versus doing it for the passion
like almost like a religious religious
missionary right to say yeah you don't
do it for the money you do it because
it's it's it's your love and life and
and and that's a very powerful
approach to developing a very resilient
mindset to the roller coaster ride of
entrepreneurs
yeah
so
just to close just to close on this one
mike um if you told them you know if an
investor gives you a hundred thousand
dollars to do your startup
if you're only doing it for the money
what are you going to do when you run
out of money
you know you're going to quit
and an investor wants somebody who's
going to find the next check
exactly it took steve jobs two years to
raise its first money
and so this is what people want to see
resilience and like i said this applies
today not just in entrepreneurship but
in all walks of life
if you start a relationship where you
know
it's only something that you know is not
going to last forever then that
relationship is not going to last
forever
and so indeed there has to be something
deeper here
so you know what uh i want to hit a
couple of the questions that are coming
in here um
you know so
related to all of this something
what tactic can help to embrace
uncertainty what tricks and tips and
devices would recommend and and you know
so
my thoughts on this one of them of
course is is this bifurcation to
understand that
uncertainty in your personal life and
your comfort with it versus uncertainty
or comfort in your professional life can
be two very different things and just
that alone is is a wonderful device for
helping you think about your
relationship with uncertainty and
developing a more result and said the
other thing that you've said
is that comfort with uncertainty is a
muscle and like every muscle it must be
exercised it must be focused on it must
be you know worked out and so the notion
of you know just like going to the gym
every day there's no trick or shortcut
to having a healthy physique right no
you've got to do your work and it's
consistent you know the kinds of things
that i can think would be good is you
know
more come closer learn a foreign
language
you know do something outside of your
normal comfort zone every day to push
that boundary to kind of keep working
that muscle doesn't do big things it can
be small things in either one of the
portions of your life are there other
ways that um
are there other ways
that you can think of that can that can
help folks try to embrace this
uncertainty in a very sort of real way
um
i mean
you know
like i said it's a muscle
let me give you another example uh i i
had class this morning here at ie and um
they were all telling me how do we
increase our emotional intelligence
and i said to them in your work groups
you got eight of you in a work group and
every one of you in that work group all
eight of you are coming from different
cultures different nationalities
when you're dealing with people that are
diverse every day
your muscle is increasing
you know you're becoming more
emotionally intelligent
you're dealing
and emotional intelligence is a lot
about uncertainty because you don't know
how other cultures behave you don't know
what's important to them all these
things create uncertainty and so the
more you get used to them the more
you're thrown into the pool
the better and so you know one way is to
move people around in different
departments
um you know send them to another country
yeah i mean you name it there are many
different ways
to to do this to grow this muscle
yeah absolutely absolutely all right so
so so getting back to our list right we
had
see opportunity uncertainty harness the
emotion of others
know whether you're a missionary or a
mercenary
the next one you have listed here is
know your strengths and your weaknesses
and i think this has a lot more to do
with confidence
and the role that self-confidence has in
your relationship with uncertainty than
anything else but but i'd like to hear
your thoughts
know your strengths and weaknesses
yeah um
we talk a lot about
strengths and weaknesses
and you know for most people
they have a hard time measuring this
and so
what we're doing now with the research
uh is we're actually measuring
a person across several dimensions
uh one is their comfort with uncertainty
which we can measure now
and just like you can measure you know
someone's iq or some or the temperature
you know whether someone has fever or
not we're getting to the point where we
can actually measure
how comfortable a person is with
uncertainty in their personal and their
professional
now beyond that there are other things
you need to measure in terms of
strengths and weaknesses one of them is
personality traits
okay and that's another thing we're
starting to measure and obviously
emotional intelligence
and so
if you could get to the point where you
would have like a dashboard and this is
essentially what we're calling it
where you could look and see a snapshot
of where you are
in the different elements
that have to do with either competencies
uh traits
uh emotional intelligence comfort
uncertainty you will have a better idea
of yourself and the things that you need
to develop
you see you you cannot have a one
stop shop here one size fits all
everybody is different
and and this is very important you know
because for example we're now going into
companies where we're actually seeing
for example at one company
uh most of the people looked at
different departments most of the people
that were more comfortable with
uncertainty were in the accounting
department
and you were like
now why do we need that
uh and so
it's very important to understand
people's comfort with uncertainty and
their strengths and weaknesses and i
think we need to start measuring that i
need to and people need to start
understanding and taking ownership
of their personal development roadmap
can't be just the companies
individuals need to take ownership of
that because
knowing your strengths and weaknesses is
going to be critical in differentiating
yourself in the future
indeed indeed
um so so uh you know a number of
questions let's actually get the
uh the the checklist and and and so
knowing your strengths and your
weaknesses who you are as a person being
able to actually create these you know
metrics and and and and viewpoints um is
is a is an important part because as as
you know whoever said it peter drucker
jack welch you name it you know if you
can measure it
you can manage it and and and so that's
that's an important component of this
and so you know that's where that
dashboard of
to now for the first time
be able to help individuals measure
their level of comfort with uncertainty
see how their relationship with
uncertainty is different in their
professional and personal lives and and
and and that's really i think a
breakthrough
in this area where where you're you're
absolutely leading the cutting edge of
research in this space
you know so the fifth one
right and i think this goes to one of
the questions that was asked uh by one
of the participants and they asked how
much of your background in sales and
marketing and other things has helped
you in your in your journey
the fifth
piece right first was opportunity in
uncertainty
harness the emotions of others
missionary versus mercenary know your
strengths and weaknesses and the last is
see yourself as a salesperson
entrepreneurial life is one
long pitch
and so what do you mean when you say
that and how do you think that relates
your background in sales
um
yeah
this is this is critical um
i truly believe that our you know your
life is a continuous pitch you're always
selling yourself
and you need to make
the right impression
quickly one word that i think
doesn't get enough credit in the world
today is the word rhetoric
logos ethos
and so
we're surrounded by people that think
that you can live the world with logos
only
which is to make rational statements
about things and you know
logic
but the reality is that you know you
have logos which is rational statements
ethos which is your credibility and
pathos which is and those are the three
elements of rhetoric the emotions that
you stir in others
and so this goes back to meaning
people aren't interested in what you
tell them it's how it's how you make
them feel
and so when you are talking to people
you need to inspire them
steve jobs the former steve jobs for
example he was amazing at inspiring
people he could have got up in las vegas
remember las vegas 2008 2009 he could
have got up and said you see this device
it's going to allow you to search the
web
you know write emails and look at
pictures and talk he could have said
that that would have been 100 logos
but what did he say he said do you see
this device
it's going to change your life
and millions of people believed him
when you're living in a world like we
are today and it's going to get worse
where people don't want rational
messages
they want messages that make them feel
better that give their lives meaning
you're going to have to know how to sell
you're going to have to know how to stir
their emotions you're going to have to
know how to lead how to inspire
and that takes emotional intelligence
and that's a critical part
of business today
and and and this and this and the
relationship that that idea has with no
resilience is if you have deep within
you the ability
to communicate on a very very intense
level with your customers with your team
with everyone around you
will be able to make it through those
low points and you will be able to
manage it through those high points
you know so
so uh yeah that sort of brings us to the
end of the five right so opportunity and
uncertainty harnessing the emotions of
others missionary versus mercenary
mindsets knowing your strengths and
weaknesses and seeing yourself as a
salesperson what again were those three
components of rhetoric that you thought
were so important just so folks can
write them down
logos
the rational the logic
ethos your credibility
and pathos the emotions that you stir in
the
audience awesome see yeah
great points and help us break it down
yeah when we hear the word rhetoric
uh we always think of you know julius
caesar you know uh ronald reagan maybe
stuff like that um
yeah and so but the reality is that 99
of our world is rhetoric
only algebra maybe physics i don't know
you know more about faces than i do but
everything is socially constructed so
economics you name it and so it's very
important to teach young people early to
be able to use pathos to their advantage
and to to use it to
communicate because people need that
today they need to be inspired
yeah
oh in indeed i want to get to a few
questions
and we'll uh we'll look um to keep our
our our discussion between you and i
reasonably short so that we can hit a
few of these because i know we can talk
about these these topics uh for for
hours on end
um
so you know
failure is
a big part of the entrepreneurial
experience and overcoming failure and
seeing it as a stepping stone to your
ultimate goal versus the end of the line
so to speak
is is something that every entrepreneur
has to start to come to terms with them
and and how do you see that as part of
resilience and i guess for me it
connects somewhat to this missionary
versus mercenary mindset um and and and
and whether or not
you know you you have the fortitude
resilience to push through right
yeah no i i totally agree with you mike
uh this is about you know why you do
what you do
uh if you're a mercenary as soon as you
don't have that instant gratification uh
the money is there you're gonna quit
and so failure is critical uh because
you learn from failure and that's why so
many
um
investors actually
you know they'd like to see that someone
has failed several times because you're
going to learn that way i'll never
forget i had a student of mine from
israel
and uh
he started a startup raised a million
and a half after two years he lost all
the money of his investors
so he started another start
guess where he went he went back to the
same investors
and they invested in him
because they said this guy has learned
and and so you know
this is part of the resilience that you
build up
by learning through doing and feeling
well and as long as that failure is not
due to your
personal you know
uh your your your personal actions
things like this there are myriad ways
and pathways for a a startup to fail
and and it sort of goes back to that who
you are as a person and making sure that
that's okay
um
the uh you know you had talked a little
bit about you know teaching young people
rhetoric and the components of rhetoric
and how to be a better you know
communicator whether that's a
salesperson or whether that's a team
leader um one of the questions came in
from a participant said i'm 17.
what do you think can help me grow as an
entrepreneur and i love this question
because i love the fact that young
people
are interested in this topic and they
want to know how to make themselves
better so paris i want you to go back to
17 year old paris de la travis and what
would you have told yourself to say what
do you think you do to grow as an
entrepreneur right now
when i was 17 i was delivering the los
angeles times
every morning getting up at five in the
morning putting rubber bands around each
paper and then getting out there on my
bike and hitting the neighborhood in the
door
i had a paper route too great job
yeah so at 17
you need to start getting out of your
comfort zone um you know i think you
need to learn about rhetoric
and things like that but i think it's 17
the most important thing is
you know
and they did a lot of research about
this they took in london they took
five-year-old kids
and they saw that at
five years old 92 percent of them were
creative
and then they followed those
five-year-old kids until they were 15
and at that point only 17 were creative
what happens to us between the ages of 5
and 15
education it puts us in a box
and so if i was 17 years old i would
real you know i would want to realize
that we are being trained for a
predictable world
in school
and the world is more and more uncertain
and now that's not going to change
anytime soon
so i would be doing things that get me
out of my comfort zone i'd be trying to
get much more used to uncertainty
i i would do things you know
it's like if you you need to feel the
pain you got to get comfortable with the
uncomfortable
that's how you grow
and once again we go back to that
analogy to the muscle
right no pain no gain everybody knows
that those first few days after you
start to go to the gym or january 2nd
and 3rd after you make that new year's
resolution to work out and run every day
or whatever might be those are painful
days physically painful because you're
starting to grow that muscle but then as
all of us have experienced after a few
weeks after a few months the pain is
gone and and in many regards there's a
yearning for that activity for that
continued development and growth and and
after not working out for a couple days
you're like man i really
have to go and do this and i think that
speaks towards this
this resilience in mindset
in that you become not only used to
being comfortable with uncertainty and
managing it but that you once again see
it as an opportunity and you want to
grow in that space but but it goes back
to that analogy of the muscle
right
absolutely
all right um
so
look you grew up in la that in itself is
its own culture
so then you go to boston
you move to manhattan
you then go to london
you deal a lot with
asian cultures doing your sort of sports
marketing bringing european football
clubs to japan for for friendlies
now you're in spain
um
one of the questions that comes up is
how do cultural influences
you know interact with five points and
are these five points to some extent pan
cultural or do some of them really ch
change a bit if you're dealing in a
different culture and and you know your
breadth of experience in dealing with
various cultures i think is helpful to
try to understand
um yeah that's a very good question a
lot of people ask me
are you a citizen of the world or what
um
and
let me tell you uh your identity
is very important i think and i think
during covid our identities were even
more reinforced
i understand
lots of cultures
i have a lot of emotional intelligence
professionally
but for me my identity as an american is
critical it's it's one of those things
that gives you meaning in your life
and i think that we should you know
resp
respect but we should realize that our
identities are an important part of who
we are
and at the same time we need to be able
to embrace other cultures
we need to be able to embrace diversity
and
part of that is having the emotional
intelligence to not judge other people
but to see the richness in the different
cultures
and i think that's part of the
resilience you know we're living in a
world today that's more global than ever
it's local and global
and that's not going to go away i think
and i think that's part of our strength
because our identity is but also gives
us internal meaning
but i think culture is a very important
factor here being able to understand all
these different cultures
because it's a muscle the more different
cultures that you're exposed to you know
the better i mean i went to for the
first time i went to baku uh a couple
weeks ago
and people might ask well where the hell
is baku i didn't know where it was uh
but i thought i gotta go there because
it's a new place and sure enough
amazing country uh azerbaijan amazing
people
and i you know i feel richer from having
being exposed to that culture
and so i think you know we need to
embrace culture we don't you know
it's not about being afraid of being
exposed to other cultures
it's you know you need to get
comfortable with the uncomfortable
because then it becomes comfortable
and you're a better person that way
yeah yeah
all right last question before we wrap
up our webinar
uh and before i ask it i want to just
once again uh thank you for joining us
from across the uh both both north
america and the atlantic today um uh to
talk about this fascinating topic that
we don't think about nearly enough
when we talk about entrepreneurship you
know often we'll talk about the
technical challenges of the product
we'll talk about the financial
challenges of raising money we'll talk
about all these things but often we
lose you know uh
the viewpoint that every single one of
those steps involves people
and that's an important component to
this
right
and and the other thing i would say is
you know for those that that that are
thinking about doing some of our
programs at stanford you know one of our
frameworks on how to think about
building a company so much of it starts
with team
and teams about people
and so i think that this topic of of
your resilience as an entrepreneur and
how you really
well how you relate to uncertainty in
your professional and personal life
is is so important all right so the
final question i think it's a fun one
you had mentioned that you were on wall
street during the 1980s
what's your favorite hollywood movie
about
wall street in that time or elsewhere
and what character would you have played
oh boy you got me there um
leonardo dicaprio
oh
wolf of wall street
yes
um
but i i want to make a final point uh
mike on people
because this is important um
you know
there's a great book that i didn't write
i don't have any shares in it
uh written by the gallup organization
called it's the manager
and
what they say in that book is that we're
living in a world today where about 80
percent of the people are not engaged in
their jobs
they're what i call friday people
they're looking forward to the weekend
now
we cannot live in a world where 80
percent of the people are not engaged in
their jobs
because
you know like i said 40 percent of our
life is work
and that's why entrepreneurship is so
critical because a lot of people when
they become entrepreneurs they become
monday people and they love their jobs
but the reality is that most of the
world are not going to be entrepreneurs
and so we need to help people get
engaged in their jobs and that's part of
the work that we're doing
is in looking at you know this dashboard
is essentially to try to understand
people better and see within their work
environments how we can get them to
become more engaged
and what this book says in 20 years of
research of the gallup organization is
that it's the manager
the manager is the reason why people are
not engaged in their jobs our managers
need to be better coaches they need to
be better mentors
that is what it's going to give us the
inspiration the the the the motivation
to be much more engaged in our jobs
and and i think that's a critical
component it's all about people whether
it's in the team in a in a startup or a
team in a company you need to be a
monday person you need to love mondays
live life is way too short to be a
friday person the rest of your life
and so i think we need to do more
and this is an area that we're starting
to spend a lot of time on is helping
companies
get their employees to become much more
engaged through teaching you know
managers to become better mentors
coaches and the like
so i just want to part with that
you need to love my it
it's a great point one of the ways to do
that is to not go into the weak
uncertain and fearful but rather to see
it as an opportunity kind of going back
to being said all right i want to thank
you once again we tried to get to as
many questions as we could of course we
can't get to all of them but i want to
thank all of our participants for
putting their questions in i tried to
get to as many as possible while
allowing us to go into the depth that we
wanted to so thank you once again for
once again professor de la trois
you